hallo ihr lieben ich zeig euch heute
etwas sehr einfaches was schnell geht
aber dennoch brutal lecker ist und
zweier plätzchen gefüllt mit sahne und
außen rum mit kokosraspeln und alles was
wir dafür benötigen sind zwei pakete
diese eier plätzchen
die findet ihr in jedem supermarkt
außerdem 800 milliliter schlagsahne
entweder drei esslöffel zucker oder ein
esslöffel zucker und ein esslöffel
vanille extrakt und acht kinder free
sahnesteif das entspricht vier packungen
und anschließend benötigen wir noch ein
liter milch und 200 gramm kokosraspeln
als allererstes wird die kalte
schlagsahne steif geschlagen das mache
ich mir zum beispiel in einer
küchenmaschine
es geht aber auch mit dem handmixer oder
sogar mit dem schneebesen das dauert
dann noch etwas länger
nachdem die sahne dann eine minute lang
aufgelockert wurde kann auch schon das
war eine stadt mit la cruz und auch der
zucker und ob man diese exakt und dann
sieht das ganze komplett starten
[Musik]
damit ich die kekse einfacher befüllen
kann nehme ich mir jetzt meine
spritzbeutel für hilfe und fülle die
sahne hinein
[Musik]
jetzt kommt auch schon der spaß sie
geteilt das nimmt ihr euch einen keks
spricht da etwas war aufnimmt dann ein
zweiter klick als deckel und dann wird
das ganze erstmal in die milch gepumpt
und danach in die kokosraspeln da gibt
es so viele möglichkeiten ihr könnt auch
zwischen die sahne noch nutella rein
spritzen oder marmelade lemon gehört
alles wonach euch ist lasst eurer
fantasie der freien lauf aus den
genannten zutaten erhaltet ihr circa 80
plätzchen
damit könnt ihr in kürzester zeit viele
leute glücklich machen
[Musik]
die rezepte idee habe ich übrigens von
der lieben ml sie hat ein sehr cool
instagram account auf dem sie aktuelle
angebote tipps und auch lustige dinge
teilt es ist einfach für jeden was dabei
und ich kann euch nur am herd legen ihr
dort zu folgen wenn es nicht schon tot
ich sage euch links ihrer bei teenie
infobox
[Musik]
jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und dach bis zum
nächsten mal objektiv sketchen
[Musik]